[Music]
i find beauty in this world beauty and
the girls that find beauty in the sports
beauty and this music i mean truly and
of course i find beauty and whatever we
do better than the boys i mean
fluorescent shields get illegal in
boxing ran past quick like i'm sydney
mclaughlin i set mad pics till i'm fully
exhausted or made me cross such chicks
like i'm alia boston or asia wilson
between step pivot i score gold medals
just amongst three women
caitlyn clark she been about to score
when i speak on triple doubles i mean
tens across the board
chloe kim looks like magic on the ice
she won a golden 17 and then came back
and did it twice and then at 18. when
suny lee approached the bean triple back
hand spring with the perfect landing
naomi osaka way to go mama fourth time
grand slam champ go bonkers coco golf
back hand running youngest player
ranking in that top 100 trinity robin
wrote no literally highest contract i
mean ever in the history unstoppable
just saying that it's possible when you
see them young girls and knowing that
they watching knowing that they're there
knowing that they care talent within
women that they knowing that they share
respect
it's different
if you pivot
just don't quit it
just live it
don't quit
don't quit
you